this crazy Big Bang Theory cast photo
explained
kaley cuoco instagrammed a picture
saying the entire cast is sick what is
going on literally everyone is sick
literally everyone's getting sick all
the time I think my mom gets it from her
kids so I'm guessing their kids and they
come to work and we're all hugging and
we're all very close right so it's funny
we will achieve win scenes and maybe
like took off the mask see our lines
like this and put it back on we had to
bring the doctor to set like three times
they're all taking like Tamiflu or
whatever it is I hope because this care
package is a joke we talked with Kunal
Nayyar at the UCLA Institute of the
environment and sustainability gala
he says the cast all tries to eat
healthily because of their intense
shooting schedule but one person might
just beat out the rest
who's the healthiest person in the cast
me I never get sick let's get off of
India so I've seen every kind of
bacteria you can imagine I know Kaylee
like loves her yoga does Kaylee do the
yoga on set teach it to you have yoga
Thursdays so at lunch she teaches us all
yoga on Thursdays can you show me one
move oh I know I'm Indian I was
wondering it